my dream house
with the house I recently with my girlfriend
bought I love old houses in the middle of the city
I think that's cool
this is the voicemail of young political The Hague
leave 1 message after the tone
the elderly will be hard of hearing on the housing market
resulting in many family homes
prescription suffers from the elderly
so that will not be able to start later
that is what politics is all about
to persevere with the elderly in the housing market
we want to get away from the housing market and
towards public housing
so that there will be more affordable housing
that are available to everyone
therefore also for starters and young families
we want 1 special mortgage for starters
making it easier
to buy your first home
and that you also pay less in the beginning
and as you later
will earn more and pay a little more
but with the starter mortgage
you can also sell 1 affordable home
there are only 10 percent of young people
who have 1 rental home
what can you do about this
we think it is important to get started
many more homes are coming
and then also for all groups
so for the middle class but also for social rent
and we just simply do that
by building more homes
1 affordable home
how it is now
is that people have sometimes been on 1 waiting list for 10 years
and that's why we want much more
sustainable social rental housing
going to build
we also want to increase the maximum income limit
so that more people
eligible for 1 social rental home